If you want to understand what I've done
I needed to find a way to outlive my
daughter so I began my experiments in
search of immortality I've made some
adjustments to people Larry anyone I get
close to it always ends in pain
Rita sometimes the easiest pain to
ignore as our own Jane I've got 64
personalities I'm Miranda
penny farthing Sir baby doll duh! hey Siri what's
the Doom Patrol stop doing that my
name's Vic I'm dealing with some kind of
post-traumatic stress booyah and
you Cliff.
What's up with his daughter Dorothy's
missing. She will unleash hell on
earth I told you to be polite and you
will be powerless to stop it. help me find her.
I don't know how you
handle things like this typically we
just kind of wing it
so you wanna become a superhero
nooo!
my powers have gotten pretty
impressive
now I'm going to go get a ladder
those annoying eckless losers
that I live with are my family they may
be spineless but I know deep down they
all care about me
ready for a hug!
if we want to be a team we have to make the effort
time to take out the trash
Let's go!
Welcome back everyone is Charlie they
just dropped the HBO trailer for Doom
Patrol season 2 so we'll break it down
there's a bunch of Justice League Easter
eggs there's also a lot of stuff going
on with HBO max the Justice League
Snyder cut there's been a lot of rumors
about Batman HBO series plans that I
added to the video in DC's overall
programming strategy with its Green
Lantern HBO series in the Justice League
dark HBO series they just announced so
I'll explain what's going on with all
this in HBO max if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all
the Easter eggs will do a new Amazon
giveaway all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and let me know what you
want them to do for their next big DC
crossover if they have all these huge
shows coming to HBO we'll start with a
Doom Patrol footage then I'll explain
the larger DC universe crisis on
Infinite Earths Justice League stuff in
the Justice League Snyder cut stuff
separately if you have no idea what's
going on with Doom Patrol they were
featured during crisis on Infinite
Earths this is all taking place on earth
21 the Doom Patrol is technically a
spin-off of the Titans TV series but
they changed some things when the Doom
Patrol series actually premiered so they
just said that it was often a different
universe just to explain the continuity
errors even if he didn't watch the
series you probably recognize some of
those characters or some of those actors
it's based mostly on Grant Morrison's
super weird super trippy Doom Patrol
comic book run so during the trailer the
chief played by Timothy Dalton explains
the plot of season 1 James Bond himself
he basically created each of those
different members for specific reasons
that they get into during season 1 I'll
explain that in a second but then they
give a rundown of each of the different
team members just for people that have
never seen the series before because
it's coming to HBO max it's reaching a
way wider audience which is part of the
reason for putting it on HBO max so you
have a whole bunch of people that
probably see this and have no idea
what's going on and don't realize that
it's actually a DC TV show they start
with negative man played by Matt Bomer
he has a radioactive soul/self that he
can astral project it has electrical
properties so it can interact with other
objects and people and help him but
while he's astral projecting his regular
body is completely vulnerable and he can
only do it for a limited amount of time
or he'll die alaska woman's powers are
exactly what
they sound like she can stretch herself
she can reform her body to any shape
that she was so she can use it to change
her appearance or grow super-huge but
she's really terrible at it right now
cyborg is exactly what you remember from
the Justice League they haven't quite
got into any of his crazy mother box
Darkseid or New Gods stuff with this
version of the character but they do
have their own version of STAR Labs on
the show just like the flash TV show
just like on Justice League
crazy Jane was probably one of the best
characters on the show last year just
like she says in that trailer she has 64
different personalities each one of them
has a different superpower some of them
are more powerful than others some of
them are more for comedy some of them
are a little bit scarier some of them
are a little bit crazier she's a little
bit like Marvel's legion character in
that she has so many different
personalities and each one has a
different superpower Brendan Fraser is
robot man he's a former race car driver
whose body was destroyed in a car
accident a long time ago the chief put
his brain inside the robot body so he's
kind of like a walking head in a jar he
drops a lot of f-bombs on the show you
see a little bit of what's going on
during season one there's not a whole
lot of alan tudyk smiston Oh buddy
character but he was one of the best
characters on any DC TV show or even
movies for that matter he was completely
crazy
he has god-tier extra dimensional powers
that I'll explain in a second but I
don't know how much of him is going to be
in season two because the new threat is
actually in the Chiefs daughter Dorothy
spinner here obviously a reference to
Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz but she
has crazy god-tier powers as well she's
the character that looks like she
stepped out of the Twilight Zone episode
I have the beholder where everyone on
earth had the weird faces but the
beautiful woman was the ugly one they're
doing the version of the character that
Grant Morrison did when he did his Doom
Patrol run and it had a lot to do with
something called the matter Opticon
which was a device created by dr.
destiny a villain that had the ability
to create reality from the fabric of
dreams so as you can see in the trailer
they're just saying that she has those
powers naturally like a metahuman her
God - your powers of creation to change
reality or create anything that she
wants to make it real not just an
illusion
that's why the chief is telling them
that if they don't help his daughter she
could wind up destroying the world and
they would be powerless to stop her
so that's the big threat of season 2
during season 1 when you get the
backstories on everyone and you learned
that he actually created the accidents
that gave them their metahuman abilities
you learned that he did it because he
was searching for a way to try and
expand his lifespan so that he could
live long enough to find a cure to help
his daughter because her powers are just
so off the charts crazy I think a really
good comparison to make would be
Franklin Richards in the Marvel Universe
Franklin Richards probably the most
powerful person next to Galactus in the
Marvel comic book universe they haven't
said much about what's going on with the
other villains on the show or big
crossovers or anything like that yet
it's still pretty early in the season
but it's all going to be dropping on HBO
max they're claiming right now that not
all the DC shows are going to be coming
to HBO max they're trying to curate it a
little bit more so they're trying to
keep the series that they do put on HBO
max a little more higher quality a
little more top-tier that's why they
said that they're spending movie level
money like one hundred fifty hundred
sixty million dollars making the Green
Lantern HBO TV series the JJ Abrams
Justice League dark TV series then you
have all the Justice League Snyder cut
stuff is coming to HBO max which is kind
of going to be a six episode maxi series
technically it's a movie but it's also
being dropped in the way that a TV
series would be dropped with one episode
per week we also learned a little bit
more about that to the actor who plays
Darkseid in the Justice League Snyder
cut was dropping more teasers about
scenes that he has with Batman there's a
lot of Darkseid that's being added back
in to Justice League Snyder cut I've
already done a couple videos about that
the changes that they made the deleted
scenes what Zack Snyder is changing it's
basically a completely different movie
than the Justice League theatrical cut
so Zack Snyder's original plans for
Justice League or a completely different
storyline completely different story
arcs for the characters they'll be
releasing the Snyder cut next year they
haven't announced an official release
date but it sounds like it's going to be
sometime in the spring of 2021 because
they're basically going through
post-production they won't be filming a
ton of extra scenes but they will be
doing extra dialogue to sort of stitch
the scenes together the Zack Snyder is
putting back in the movie or that he's
constructing his version of the movie
from it'll be like a four four and a
half hour movie broken into six
different
parts 30 to 40 minutes each basically
this big act breaks big WTF moments
pushing you into the next episode I'll
link some of the other videos that I've
done for that at the end of this too
just because we have learned quite a bit
about it the other real big stuff that's
going on is all the Titan season 3 stuff
they're doing a lot of Batman people
always wonder if you could do Batman on
TV but what's going on during season 3
is that they're introducing Barbara
Gordon Batgirl in Oracle I believe she's
going to be Oracle when she comes on to
this show but there'll be a bunch of
flashbacks to her as Batgirl as well so
they're kind of doing every version of
Barbara Gordon I know there are a lot of
people that heard rumors about an HBO
Batman series so there were rumors about
them doing the plot of the Ben Affleck
Batman movie when it was still going to
be Ben Affleck doing that instead of
Robert Pattinson and Matt Reeves doing
their version of the Batman it was going to
be a big Arkham Asylum Deathstroke
Batman story as far as I know those
rumors are not true
and HBO does not have plans to do any
major Batman story with Ben Affleck
outside of the Snyder cut Justice League
stuff that's going on I will completely
flip if they ever did a Batman HBO
series everybody would flip so if we
hear anything about that that sounds
like it's real of course I'll do a video
about it everyone just post all your
reactions and your big questions in the
comments below if you haven't seen Doom
Patrol yet either check it out on HBO
max it's a rad series it's super trippy
and super weird but click here for my
full Justice League Snyder cut teaser
trailer in Easter eggs video and click
here to learn about the new version of
the Joker that's coming to the new
Batman movies thank you so much for
watching everyone stay safe
I'll see you guys tonight!